antonin de christine vélia et céline
deregnaucourt chez epsilon jeunesse
antonin est pas la plage pour la
première fois sur le sable tout le monde
s'active château jeux de ballons et
bains de soleil dans l'eau tous rigole
tous seul fantôme eu antonin a peur il
se met à penser à l'eau calme de son
montant les amendes entonna reviennent
sur le sable avec lui les équipes se
forment pour jouer au ballon
soudain le vin en porte la casquette
préférée d'anthony ma casquette
entonnant doit sauver sa casquette sens
magny penser le voilà dans l'eau
lorsqu'en tome 1 mais sa tête sous l'eau
pour prendre sa casquette et auquel
surprise un band apogon joue à cache
cache dans les coraux un peu plus loin
une carence bleus passent près d'antonin
ignorant sa présence au détour de
quelques algues un poisson chirurgien
fait un festin un poisson épervier part
à la chasse très vite
antonin est rejoint par ses amis tous
sont émerveillés devant la beauté de
l'ange empereur maintenant tout le monde
peut jouer dans l'eau antonin a retrouvé
sa casquette et oublier sa peur c'est
déjà l'heure de rentrer antonin est le
dernier à sortir 2